the American landscape is shifting
before our eyes
race it to the top life big changes hi
Henry hi Katie
big challenges I hate to admit but I
probably am prejudiced in a world that's
more complicated than ever how many of
you have been shipped that creeps me out
would you consider yourself a neo-nazi I
would not I consider myself a white
nationalist and I would consider myself
a member of your right we're teaching
kids that girls are second-class
citizens H or has become H er you think
this was a hate crime without a doubt
she died because of her to Jeff now
Houston's are shaped by American culture
there are a lot of positives but there's
some negative - I want to be your best
friend and much more maybe not the much
more part but the friends part I'm cool
with that it seems that everyone has
something to say but nobody's really
listening about my rights don't I have
rights
join me on a journey as like crisscross
the country meeting all kinds of
Americans where they live work pray and
play
who are we what do we stand for we're
trying to get paid what white women get
paid where are we going and how do we
make things better searching for truth
we think you're with the cleaning crew
yes looking for understanding how would
you describe what it's like to be Muslim
hard part getting to the heart of the
matter to have such conversations you
have to be willing to be uncomfortable
in America inside out